the trump war room or whatever it was
right right this is this is charlie
kirk's organization by the way yeah this
there there's there's not much there i
mean this is like if oh there you go i
were defended for
speaking the truth
yep exactly um oh it's a deleted tweet
he had to delete a tweet that's why we
and we're not seeing it oh yeah deleted
to tweet but they're
tweet out free charlie to support
uh tweet out [ __ ] charlie that would be
uh
[ __ ] charlie um maybe that'll get them
going
you think i should get their attention
here i don't like to give these people
attention but maybe we'll uh
maybe we'll um
hashtag [ __ ]
charlie maybe we'll get a joint are you
sure you want to type it that's what
they're going to ask maybe yeah [ __ ]
charlie there we go maybe because it's a
hashtag
[ __ ] charlie and then we'll do we'll do
this
we'll give him the old middle finger
here
let's see
dude
we're live tweeting
yeah
give him a finger and then give him a
little
oh yeah a kiss yeah yeah you know if i
can find the finger where is it at where
the hell is it at
is it not on my my thing here that's
that's really
clearly i don't use the middle finger
one um that often and you want me to
give them a kiss i'll get you a little
kiss
yeah blow them like this with the heart
or without the heart with the heart you
gotta know oh yeah
[ __ ] charlie [ __ ] charlie everyone um go
go tweet [ __ ] charlie look at that see
and because you gave it a little kiss
twitter said okay that's not so bad yeah
yeah right right they were like oh the
middle finger and the kiss you're good
to go you're good to go okay so we did
our we did our due diligence here today
uh so uh trendy trends and tweety tweets
your favorite guy won't